word had reached
justinian
nestorian monks claimed they had
successfully crossed through hostile
persian territories and traveled to the
silk routes of central asia
there at the limits of the known world
they said they had encountered the
fabled ceres the silk people at their
mysterious eastern origins they had
supposedly visited the far-flung city of
surrender in the place they called china
and had returned with an extraordinary
secret
and now they were demanding an audience
with the emperor himself
their message was for justinian emperor
of the eastern roman empire the
representative of god on this earth
and him
alone
the monks were escorted through the
great gateway leaving the noise and
confusion of the busy city street and
entered the cool of a marble entrance
hall in an antechamber they were
searched for weapons and all items that
were considered harmful were confiscated
safe for a walking stick similar to a
bamboo cane
they were escorted through small groups
of richly clad individuals who parted to
let them pass and then muttered together
speculating about the origin and mission
of these strange visitors
and finally they reached the reception
hall
of the imperial court
their guide paused to explain to them
that they might not be admitted to the
audience chamber to see justinian today
or even tomorrow but they must be
patient
they must wait even if they carried a
secret that had the potential to change
the known world
forever
the year was 550
and the emperor justinian was presiding
over a revival in roman fortunes
almost a century earlier the latinized
western half of the roman empire had
succumbed to barbarian invasions but the
greek-speaking eastern provinces had
survived the onslaught and its byzantine
emperors maintained roman traditions in
their new capital constantinople
the people of these eastern provinces
also retained roman aspirations
including military ambitions to restore
the former empire
at the start of his reign justinian had
sent armies west to reconquer north
africa and reclaim italy from its
intrusive barbarian kings
but now these strange religious
travelers have brought the imperial
court information that might change the
entire dynamic of the ancient world
economy
for the monks claimed to know the secret
of what exactly silk was and how the
ceres manufactured fabric from its
fibers
they had witnessed the process first
hand and believed they could replicate
these skilled techniques
for more than half a millennium chinese
silk had been the premier fabric of the
ancient world
it was lighter stronger and smoother
than any other cloth made from plant
fibers or animal products as a natural
fiber the finest silk was water
resistant light reflective and
maintained an elasticity absent in
linens cottons or wool it could even be
dyed vibrant colours or re-woven into
delicate translucent veils
imperial rome had succumbed to the
fashion with heavy wool and linen togas
transformed into lighter garments by the
inclusion of part silk weaves and by the
reign of justinian courtly costumes made
from silk were a special mark of rank
and status within the government of the
eastern roman empire
but the question had remained for
centuries
what was the origin of this strange and
unique material transported thousands of
miles across desert and steppe by
distant intermediaries
devout adventurers who recounted their
story to the astonished christian
emperor claimed to have the answer
they told justinian about great journeys
vast distances unknown lands and strange
peoples and in the chinese city of
surrender they had observed an eastern
secret delicate fabrics manufactured by
special captive insects
silk worms with imperial backing the
monks offered to return to surrender and
bring back the strange creatures
required to create this high-value
product
how could justinian refuse
with silk the eastern roman empire would
no longer be dependent on persian
middlemen for its most prized fabrics
the treasuries in byzantium would surge
with commercial profit and the ancient
silk routes fade from significance
justinian agreed to the mission and the
holy men set out on their secret
assignment
were the centuries of rumour and
speculation finally about to be
dispelled eons of myth and legend about
china finally blown away of course this
wasn't the first time that these two
empires had come into contact
for nearly a thousand years the ancient
world had been powered and controlled by
webs of influence and imperial ambition
working their way across central asia
from both east
and west
entire cultures had survived as
intermediaries between imperial rome and
han china as they indirectly and
sometimes directly influenced each
other's fortunes in multitudinous ways
and more than once these webs had nearly
come into direct conflict a twist of
fate or last minute change of heart the
only thing that stood against the very
real possibility
but how close
did they come
and how much
did they know
this
is that story
a story that spans a thousand years
thousands of miles and thousands of
different peoples across europe and asia
this
is the story
of ancient china
and rome
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question can you put these ancient
chinese dynasties in order the shang the
ching the chin the joe and the song
that's right the answer was
[Music]
so if you failed that miserably maybe
it's time to try magellan tv's
documentary mysteries of china an
engrossing exploration of the origins of
china how it unified and how the first
emperor's tomb was rediscovered some
2000 years later some great reenactments
really put you into the action a
fascinating story and magellan have more
than 3 000 more documentaries to choose
from on a wide range of subjects so
click on the link in the description for
an exclusive month-long free trial for
voices of the past viewers
[Music]
thanks writing in the 5th century bc the
greek historian herodotus provides the
first classical reference to the far
east
there are said to be one-eyed men and
gold-guarding griffins in the regions
beyond the acedonians
and beyond them the hyperboreans whose
lands extend as far as the sea
all these nations except the
hyperboreans are continually making war
on their
neighbours herodotus could be describing
the place where windswept passes in the
altai mountains permit travel from the
wide grasslands of the central asian
steppe into ancient mongolia
for there were ancient gold deposits in
the altai mountains and the fossilized
remains of prehistoric creatures can be
seen eroding from the gobi desert
the skulls of extinct mammoths have a
large centrally placed nasal cavity for
the trunk
this could have been interpreted as a
single eye socket by ancient peoples
unfamiliar with the true biology and
origin of these great skeletal remains
dinosaur remains including the hornless
skulls of protoceratops with their large
neck frills and distinctive beak-like
protrusions could have added to the myth
perhaps the ancient step dwellers
believed those remains were from lion
bird predators who dwelt within the
unexplored mountains
and so if griffins lived in the altai
mountains
then the semi-mythical hyperboreans the
people who dwelled beyond the north wind
whose territory reaches to the sea
might have been the ancient chinese
[Music]
to the north of ancient china lay the
gobi desert and the vast grasslands of
the mongolian steppe
the gobi itself extended from southern
mongolia as far as the bleak altai
mountains
herds of shaggy coated wild bacterian
camels roamed the shrub lands of these
desert margins and asian tigers stalked
their prey through the long reeds where
mountain streams gathered into shallow
lakes
this
was a place of desolation that was
rarely traversed
beyond this void of desert
there was china
large and sophisticated kingdoms had
existed in china as early as the 8th
century bc by 476 bc an era known as the
warring states period began and for more
than two centuries china was divided
into hostile rival kingdoms
the most westerly state the kingdom of
chin was closest to the steppe and could
obtain superior amounts for central
cavalry and war chariots
between 230 and 225 bc the qin conquered
their main rivals and finally brought to
the core territories of ancient china
under a single imperial regime
and indeed it was in this era that the
qin built a great wall to protect
prosperous agricultural lands from the
mounted nomads who occupied this step
the chinese scholar sumachian records
that meng tian the general who completed
the wall lamented the destruction of the
sacred landscape with long ditches and
earthen ramparts
i have committed a crime for which i
merit death
beginning at lin tau and extending to
the aodong i made ramparts and cut
ditches over more than ten thousand li
but how could i avoid cutting through
the very veins of the earth
this is my crime
chinchi huang the first emperor chin was
buried in a vast mausoleum guarded by a
regiment of life-sized terracotta
soldiers
beneath a vast mound is the still
unexplored palace tomb of the first
emperor
according to sumachian the burial
chamber contains a giant relief map of
the known world including seas and
rivers flowing with liquid metal
quicksilver
light reflective
mercury
[Music]
but the classical civilizations of
greece and rome was situated far beyond
the limits of the known world
in 202 bc following a brief civil war
the chinese empire was restored and
secured under a more successful
government and the regime of the
renowned han dynasty officially began
under han rule china emerged as the
largest and most powerful empire in the
entire ancient world
but the chinese had a problem
a lack
of horses
the step was strategically important
because chinese territory was not well
suited for raising horses consequently
the han empire became dependent on a
step nation called the uag to provide
essential horses for its cavalry war
wagons and chariots the nomad uag
occupied an arid territory to the west
of china called the hershey corridor
which seemed to be at the edge of the
habitable world
but all this was to no avail in 209 bc a
powerful confederation of mounted nomads
called the shangnu gained dominance on
the mongolian step
warfare was a part of life for the
people who dwelt in these grassland
territories
shangnu chiefs could amass enormous
armies that included several hundred
thousand mounted warriors the han
government decided the only course of
action was to seek peace by granting the
shangnu large amounts of tribute great
quantities of grain and multiple bales
of unique
chinese
silk
and this is how the first silk traded
from hand to hand through many step
nations which lands far beyond china
information about the origin of this
valuable material was garbled by
translation through many languages and
dialects any details about the chinese
that accompanied these exchanges would
have been intermixed with speculation
wild assumptions
and myth
[Music]
[Music]
in the roman era the city port of
alexander was not only the political
capital of egypt but a center of
knowledge culture and learning
in the alexandrian museum a monumental
complex dedicated to the nine muses of
the arts there was a world-renowned
library the ptolemaic kings had begun a
collection of all the written texts in
the greek world papyri scrolls were
piled high in stacks held in shallow
shelves while scribes sat ready to
replicate any text that might be
required
over the years the greatest works of
every branch of cultural learning had
been gathered to be studied copied and
preserved
it is known that the greek historian
strabo used this library
and at the turn of the first century a.d
amongst its crowded shelves he
discovered a unique account written
about a hundred years earlier by
apollodorus of artemita
artemita was a greek-style city that lay
beyond the tigris river and from this
source strabo was able to learn details
about political developments in the
furthest reaches of the eastern world he
was attempting to describe
he describes the first appearance of a
strange new nation on the eastern
borders of bactria they were known as
the tacarians a mounted people who
emerged from unknown lands to challenge
greek supremacy in the region
the best-known nations in the east are
those who deprived the greeks of bactria
they are the asians passions tacarians
and saccharoles who came from the
country on the far side of the jacksons
opposite the sackus and the sagdians
but who were the tarkarians
in 150 bc a step nation called the
sackass had surged across the oxus river
frontier and overran the already
weakened greco-bactrian kingdom in
afghanistan as strabo explains this saka
invasion was prompted by the arrival of
a newcomer population into their
territories
he calls these people the takari
which was a greek name for the uag
these uag had completed a 2 000 mile
exodus that had taken a generation to
accomplish and now having fled fought
and negotiated their way through the
heart of asia the eug had seized the
sacca homelands and were poised to
conquer bactria
and this same incident is also
documented in the ancient historical
records
of han china
when the great euro ji went westward
they defeated and drove away the psy
king who fled southwards
and so this steppe invasion was the
first historical event to be described
in both western and eastern records two
distant worlds had collided and their
fates and fortunes were now
interlocked
[Music]
because of the excellence of our
warriors and the strength of our horses
the shangnu has eradicated the
every member of that nation has now been
slaughtered or forced into submission
in 174 bc shangnu hordes had suddenly
surged into the hershey corridor they
had overwhelmed the uag and conquered
the region the chinese learned from
foreign informants that the khan had
ordered the skull of the vanquished
chief to be made into a ceremonial
drinking goblet
they also heard stories that the
surviving uag had fled west into central
asia and escaped to a land that was far
beyond the knowledge and reach of the
chinese regime
and so in 141 bc when the emperor wu
came to power he began a monumental war
against the shangnu by his command han
armies launched successive military
expeditions into the far north they
crossed intervening deserts and marched
deep into the vast step to wage war on
the enemy during this conflict emperor
wu realized that foreign allies were
needed to control the steppe and replace
the great losses incurred by chinese
cavalry
and so
wu remembered uag
he wondered if they could be contacted
in whatever distant region of the far
west they had flared after their defeat
by the chongnu
but what lands extended to the west of
china
only a seemingly endless wasteland of
desert and steppe encircled by
impassable mountain barriers
by 128 bc the shangnu had many chinese
captives in their camps
but none seemed to have accepted their
fate with as much passive resignation
as jung chen
shangnu settlements were mobile and
resembled small towns with clusters of
large dome-like dwellings known as yurts
jung-chen had been captured 10 years
earlier brought in by outriders who
stumbled upon a large chinese delegation
passing through the southern steppe
identified as their leader he had been
brought before the great khan for
interrogation
whatever his westward mission may have
been zhang chen had obviously failed
he could be quietly dismissed from
further consideration
and so after a decade of close
supervision jung chen seemed to have
quietly accepted his position in the
camp as a permanent detainee the former
envoy appeared to have fully embraced
foreign customs taking a shung new wife
and raising his son according to nomad
traditions
but all was not
as it seemed
jung-chen had not forgotten
his mission
for he had been specially assigned by
emperor wu himself to locate and contact
the uag in the distant west
setting out westward into unknown
regions with almost 100 followers
including advisors armed guards and
foreign guides his mission was of the
utmost importance
and so
one day the camp awoke to discover that
zheng chen along with his wife his son
and companions had fled
half starved and exhausted suffering
from cold and altitude sickness they
travelled through the rock strewn passes
of the palmer mountains to enter further
unknown territories they struggled
through headache-inducing high-altitude
mountain passes towered over by
permafrost peaks and all the while they
feared pursuit and recapture by the
steppe horsemen from whom they had
recently escaped
still clutching the state emblems of the
han empire
jung chen headed into the fertile
fergana valley
and it was there he made a startling
discovery that entirely transformed
chinese perceptions of the world they
inhabited
the people who occupied the valley and
the lands beyond were part of another
advanced civilization entirely unknown
to the chinese
these strange populations did not
resemble the han people yet they had
created an advanced culture based on
agriculture cities kingdoms
and empires
although they speak different dialects
their customs are generally similar and
their language is mutually intelligible
the men all have deep set eyes and thick
beards
they are skillful at commerce and will
haggle over a small fraction
these countries produce no silk and no
varnish
and so unknown to jung chen and his
weary companions
an unplanned and unforeseen first
contact between major civilizations of
the ancient world
was about
to occur
in 330 bc alexander the great arrived in
sogdiana with his triumphant
greco-macedonian army
sogdia had been the furthest territory
of the persian empire and on its
northern frontier the broad-flowing
jaxartes river seemed to mark the limit
of the settled civilized world
the cities in this sandy wasteland were
built from mud brick hardened by the
unrelenting arid environment
beyond the river there seemed
to be nothing
patches of parched shrubland barren
hills and then endless step inhabited
only by nomad warrior horsemen
distant mountains could be glimpsed on
the horizon
but settled civilization ended at the
jaxartes
there was nobody left to conquer
except the drifting tribes of nomads
so alexander paused on this remote
frontier in this empty space on the edge
of the world he began to build a greek
style capital and military command post
this distant site occupied by greek and
macedonian veterans would stand as a
city on the edge of settled civilization
a bulwark against the neighboring steppe
it would permanently implant
mediterranean culture into the region
founded in 330 bc
this place became known as alexandria
escote
alexandria
the furthest
even today after such a long lapse of
time the descendants of these people
have retained their identity among the
wider population
this is because of the legacy of
alexander
at this location the relentless eastward
progression of the macedonian army had
been halted perhaps as they believed by
the displeasure of the gods
aristander the soothsayer the chief
diviner in the macedonian army read
numerous omens and issued a stern
warning to go no further
but alexander did not heed his advice
he ventured a single brief foray into
the step in pursuit of a large mounted
warband that had gathered on the
frontier
the steppe horseman fled into the
wastelands rapidly pursued by alexander
and his mounted host his exhausted
infantry could not keep pace and they
watched their king disappear towards the
hills and the vast emptiness of the
unknown step
fear and anxiety increased as nightfall
approached
when the royal cavalry finally came into
view and reached the safety of the
riverbank the elation of the waiting
soldiers
turned to dismay as alexander collapsed
from his mount the cavalry had been
forced to drink polluted water during
their step pursuit and now dysentery was
taking effect on the exhausted riders
the rapid pursuit in the great heat was
exhausting every man suffered from acute
thirst and as he rode alexander himself
was forced to drink whatever water he
could find unfortunately it was not pure
and gave him a severe attack of
dysentery alexander became so seriously
ill that he had to be carried back to
camp and aristander was therefore shown
to be a true prophet after all
the macedonians had learned their lesson
alexander had entered the expanse beyond
the frontiers only to be forced back by
nature itself or some indefinable will
of the gods
the greeks had reached the edge of the
known world and alexandria escote in the
fergana valley was destined to become
the furthest outpost of their
civilization
the edge
of the western world
and so alexandria escote had been in
existence for almost two centuries when
zhengcheng began his descent into the
forghana valley
by this stage the bedraggled group of
han appointees had more the appearance
of fugitives than splendid envoys from a
great empire
nevertheless the kanye inhabitants of
this hellenized region immediately
guessed the origins of the exotic
travelers
the chinese scholar sumachen reports
that jeongchen was greeted by a people
known as the da yuan
the great
ionians zhang chen was taken to
alexandria escote where an interpreter
was found
the people of this country having heard
of the wealth and productivity of china
had tried in vain to communicate with it
and when they saw zhang chen they asked
joyfully
where do you wish to go
zhengchen was escorted westward several
hundred miles to a steppe territory on
the upper oxis where the uag had settled
after their long migration but despite
his most earnest appeals he could not
persuade them to re-establish their
former alliance and send their armies
eastward he therefore traveled south to
investigate the prosperous and
well-urbanized territory of darsha
greco bactria
when zhengchen had entered bactria in
127 bc he discovered that this greek
kingdom had been disintegrating but
there was no doubting the classical
origin of these places
one of these greek cities was excavated
at the modern site of ai kanum in
eastern afghanistan icanum had a
classical theatre that could accommodate
5 000 citizens a large gymnasium avenues
lined with corinthian columns a
fortified acropolis and a persian
influenced palest center
various shrines and temples in the city
were devoted to greek gods including a
temple with iranian features that housed
a seated statue of zeus
dasha is situated over 2000 li southwest
of daiwan its people cultivate the land
and have cities and houses their customs
are like those of da juan it has no
great ruler but only several minor
magistrates ruling the various cities
the people are poor in the use of arms
and afraid of battle but they are clever
at commerce the population of the
country is large numbering a million or
more people
and so han china learnt about the
civilization of lee jan
a people emerging from the conquests of
alexander of macedon
according to chinese naming systems the
jan was therefore a dynasty that gave
its name to a people just as han china
took its name from the founding qin
empire and the succeeding han dynasty
after further dramatic encounters and
escapes from the xiangnu jung chen
finally returned to china in 124 bc
the report he delivered to the imperial
court was truly astonishing zhengchen
described entirely new and amazing
landscapes peoples animals and foliage
the emperor inspected large stone-like
seeds said to produce sweet and
delicious fruits from stunted
agricultural trees
there were also husky seeds and product
samples from a new crop said to produce
a strong and absorbent new material
linen the stories seemed impossible but
was he not holding the evidence
in his hands
within decades the imperial estates
around the emperor's summer palace were
entirely covered with foreign vegetation
including flax for the manufacture of
linen and new varieties of greek
cultivated grapevines
so
the chinese were not alone beneath the
heavens
after all
there were other civilized peoples with
different gods and sophisticated cities
beyond the wilderness that encircled the
edges of their world
this
located ancient china the middle kingdom
in a new setting below the
heavens and these distant civilizations
valued hand commodities and possessed
unique products that would enhance the
chinese economy and strengthen its
armies the west presented important
prospects for the advance of chinese
civilization
it offered the opportunity for distant
political alliances and the exploitation
of significant new resources
[Music]
but before all that there would have to
be
war
in 102 bc the well-disciplined han army
marched in ranks through the fergana
valley towards the heavily defended city
of alexandria escote
they had journeyed more than a thousand
miles across the hostile terrain
territories to reach their destination
at the eastern approaches to the tarim
basin they had traversed desiccated salt
flats with poisoned watercourses they
had skirted the intervening wastelands
following the foothills of the vast
chanshan range west to the formidable
taklimakan this impenetrable desert was
formed from red grit particles heaped
into vast shifting dune fields but those
who found their way around this obstacle
could enter the steeply ascending passes
in the rock-studded pamia mountains
the immense logistics and provisioning
involved in this enterprise had affected
all sections of chinese society but the
great cost and the risk was worth the
gamble the chinese were seeking an
incredible prize in this far-flung
territory a resource that could change
the course of world history and the fate
of their civilization
in this era chinese horses still
resembled the small pony-like breeds
depicted in the terracotta army
therefore the great greco-bactrian
horses maintained by hellenic armies was
something entirely new in the chinese
experience
they had the lineage of the mounts
alexander and his elite cavalry had
ridden to victory in iran centuries of
selective breeding had subsequently
developed persian and european stock
into a formidable animal easily able to
bear the weight of armored riders
the prestige and significance of these
prized horses can be seen on the reverse
of greco-bactrian coins
the emperor wu inspected the greek
coinage turning the detail to die struck
images over and over between his fingers
his envoys reported that these divine
riders were real they had seen soldiers
equipped in this fashion on tall
muscular mounts a breeding stock of
these prized animals would transform the
battlefield strength of han armies and
propel china into new heights of power
and potential
the cost in lives and resources to
acquire those horses might be immense
but no limits were placed on ambition
the so-called war for celestial horses
was a once in a generation event
an entire civilization marshaled massive
resources to undertake the immense task
of shortening distances across the
surface of the earth
between 123 and 119 bc the han empire
conquered the hershey corridor and
established new cities across the region
meanwhile chinese envoys carried out
expeditions into the vast tarim
territories to confirm the existence of
up to 50 oasis sites around this
inhospitable desert depression
diplomatic efforts to acquire the
fergana horses failed and the first
military expedition into the tarim
territories was a disaster due to
desertion and starvation
but the emperor was undeterred and in
103 bc mobilized a replacement army of
some 60 000 soldiers this time the han
commander li guang li was granted a vast
nearly incalculable system of provision
supplies when lee guang li finally
reached for ghana with a force of 30 000
soldiers he besieged alexandria escote
realizing the defeat was imminent the
ruling step nobles assassinated their
overlord and offered the chinese their
prized horses
following this campaign numerous tarim
states submitted themselves to chinese
rule as subject kingdoms
and so over time the networks that
connected these previously isolated
communities formed a new commercial
highway for the trafficking of unique
and valuable products
this
is how the silk roads
began
for days excited crowds had arrived in
rome
desperate for a glimpse of the triumph
of their supreme general and dictator
julius caesar returning from his
glorious conquests in gaul
those arriving early to stake their
place along the parade route were met
with a strange
and unexpected sight
on the day of the celebrations in 46 bc
the linen awnings of the roman forum had
been replaced with canopies made from
extraordinary chinese silks
rolls of this exotic eastern material
had been re-woven into translucent
sheets and died vibrant colours to
amplify the grandeur of the upcoming
spectacle caesar had
stretched awnings over the whole of the
roman forum in the sacred way leading
from his large luxurious home right up
to the capitol buildings this exhibition
of silk was thought to be even more
wondrous than the show of gladiators
that caesar offered
these strange fabrics cast a
kaleidoscope of bright colours over the
crowds and the passing parade
the streets were bathed in imperial
purples military crimsons and saffron
tinted golden yellows
the spectacle
was astonishing onlookers wondered about
the origins of this exotic material and
what it signaled about the military
ambitions of their dictator general
some might have heard stories about the
mysterious serras the silk people who
lived in a place called thaina at the
very edge of the known world
roman sailors returning from voyages to
india spoke of a mysterious place the
greeks called cerica the land from
whence comes ser the silk
its strange properties captured their
imagination
pliny had assumed that cerec silk was a
wool fiber that grew in foreign trees
and the poet virgil pictures eastern
groves where mysterious ceres comb fine
fabrics from strange leaves
but this information came from merchants
who had only sailed from egypt to india
and could not be certain what lay beyond
the ganges
a greek merchant guidebook called the
periplus of the erythraean sea records
that
it is not easy to get to this thiner
only rarely do people come from it
and even then
only a few
but not all people gathered in the
crowds viewed this silk as a symbol of
roman triumph
many soldiers considered the display to
be a reckless squandering of money that
might well have been added to their
military bonuses
it was said that the first romans to see
chinese silk were the doomed legionaries
at the battle of karai commanded by the
roman general marcus crassus crassus had
been a wealthy political ally of caesar
and for his soldiers this display of
silk in rome amounted to a betrayal
only seven years previously in 53 bc
crassus had led a roman army into
mesopotamia it was the first stage in
the conquest of the rival parthian
empire which ruled ancient persia
according to the historian orosius an
envoy warned krasus that if he continued
his invasion to seek parthian gold
he would find himself laden with the
steel of the ceres
as the mounted parthian army began their
cavalry advance across the desert plain
on a given signal they suddenly
discarded their drab coverings to reveal
gleaming armor at the same time they
unfurled brightly coloured silken
banners krasus and his legions watched
in horror as the parthians rode forward
with silk pendants billowing
dramatically above the heads of mounted
archers and heavily armored lancers
according to the roman writer flores the
parthians advanced
with their standards fluttering with
gold and silk pendants then without any
delay the cavalry closed in on all sides
showered their weapons as thick as hail
or rain upon the romans
and thus the roman army was destroyed in
terrible slaughter
under repeated volleys of barbed arrows
the incapacitated legionaries had their
arms pinned to their shields or their
sandaled feet skewered to the ground
this was the fearsome cyric steel that
the romans had been warned to expect in
the east
the parthians believed that crassus had
been motivated by plunder it was said
that they poured melted gold into the
mouth of his severed head as a symbol of
his greed
and now the parthians were marching a
captive force of 10 000 roman prisoners
of war enough to fill the ranks of two
entire legions from karai to merv at the
eastern terminal of their empire
thousands of injured defeated and
disarmed legionaries were forced to
march through narrow passes that seemed
almost scorched out of dark mountains
they were taken to the bleak desert
frontier of eastern iran more than 2 000
miles from the mediterranean coast
there was little possibility of rescue
from their fellow citizens
the strange parthian pendants first seen
at karai were made
of silk
a product manufactured only in the land
of the ceres and now during caesar's
triumph great quantities of this
material had been stretched over roman
monuments without regard to its foreign
origins or its previous use by enemies
of rome
survivors of karai who had escaped back
to roman territory looked to julius
caesar to return the fallen eagle
standards and bring back their comrades
who are now prisoners
so this display of triumphant silken
canopies on the streets of the roman
capital
was a sour and bitter sight
plotting against caesar had already
begun
but amongst the political intrigue the
question remained
what happened to this vast swathe of
prisoners sent to merv
further than any roman soldiers had ever
ventured east
the chinese outpost of li jan protected
a precious water source and rootway in
the wide network of chinese forts urban
outposts and bunker-like watchtowers
that guarded and connected the hershey
region
at first glance it seemed to be an
ordinary frontier town on the desert
margins of the hershey corridor a small
agricultural community formed from
chinese settlers and agricultural
labourers
a military unit oversaw and protected
the people of lijian but those who
passed through would have stared
intently at the unfamiliar faces of the
garrison these men with their pronounced
features and unusual eye coloration did
not resemble the han soldiers of inner
china
also the theory
goes
and in the 1950s a prominent oxford
professor named homer dubs made an
extraordinary suggestion
what if the soldiers of li-jan
were romans
the theory begins with an ancient
cadastral register from ad5 which
includes lee jian in a long list of
chinese cities and urban districts the
jan is listed in the hershey corridor
along with other outposts bearing the
names of foreign territories settled by
prisoners of war the chinese protector
general of the tarim territories led a
long-range military expedition against a
new threat on the central asian steppe
the target was a combined fortress and
palace complex under the authority of a
renegade shangnu khan named gigi
eight commemorative scenes were
specially painted to depict the chinese
attack on the steppe fortress
on the wall were coloured banners and
armed men shouting advance and engage
outside the wall horsemen galloped about
and more than a hundred foot soldiers
would come to the gate in a fish-scale
formation
but the shangnu and their step allies
did not fight in disciplined infantry
units
so who were these shield-equipped
mercenaries arranged in this strange
formation were they
roman soldiers trapped in the east
having escaped their parthian captors in
merv and finding service with step
warlords beyond the jack sartes river
could this fish scale be a distinctive
roman shield formation known as the
testudo
or tortoise
and so dubs went on to assert that
surrendering this foreign unit might
have been taken back to china as
prisoners of war now mercenaries these
survivors could have been granted a
military colony and ended their
adventures more than 5 000 miles from
the mediterranean homelands of their
ancestors
since dubb's initial claims no
archaeological evidence has been found
and even genetic testing of today's
inhabitants of the region has uncovered
no roman ancestry
dubs speculation is now widely
considered
myth
but what it does highlight is that these
two worlds were not quite as isolated
from each other as is commonly thought
there were many potential meeting points
across the vast step
what we know for certain is that a huge
quantity of the roman prisoners would
have been held prisoner at merv perhaps
expecting imminent rescue the defeat and
capture of roman legions never went
without severe retribution
for julius caesar he was completing the
conquest of gaul when news of the
horrifying defeated karai reached rome
in 46 bc with pompey and his other
rivals dead the obligation fell upon
caesar to avenge the humiliation and
restore roman prestige in the east
his legions were prepared and
far-reaching military plans were being
discussed among senior roman commanders
the sources confirm that julius caesar
was indeed planning persian conquests
that would match the achievements of
alexander the great and project roman
power beyond the frontiers of india
further east than ever before
the parthians were to be punished for
their treachery towards crassus across
the adriatic sea caesar prepared an
advanced force of 16 legions and 10 000
cavalry
a vast campaign was in preparation but
suddenly a strange rumor began spreading
among the roman populace
it was said a sinister prophecy had been
found in the sacred sibilene books
it suggested that the parthians would
only submit to a roman king
some believed that caesar wanted to
obtain this royal position for himself
and the prophecy seemed to confirm his
ambitions
the most open and deadly hatred towards
him was produced by his perceived
passion for royal power for the
multitude this was a cause of hatred and
for those who had long smothered their
hate a pretext for it
four days before his intended departure
for the eastern campaign
caesar was dead brutally stabbed to
death by his colleagues as he entered a
senatorial meeting
the body of caesar lay just where it
fell
ignominiously stained with blood
here was a man who had advanced westward
as far as britain and the outer ocean
he planned to advance east against the
parthian and indian realms so that all
land and sea might be brought into an
empire under the power of a single
leader but now there he lay no one
daring to remain or to remove the body
if the prisoners who had been marched to
mirv hoped for rescue they would not be
released by any roman army marching into
asia instead their economy would remain
connected to the silk routes only
through the activities of central asian
intermediaries
but this traffic of goods along the silk
routes was just beginning and with its
help the ancient world economy was about
to enter a new era of international
prosperity
in order to return to our ancient
standards of behavior do you know what i
will prohibit first
will it be the expanse of our
large-scale villas or the numbers of our
slaves or their many nationalities
perhaps it should be the weight of gold
and silver we own
or should it be the inappropriate
clothing worn by both men and women and
should it be especially female
extravagance
for the sake of this our wealth is
transported to strange or hostile
countries
by the first century rampant roman
consumerism had become the dominant
force in an ancient world economy that
stretched from europe to china
competitive spending among the elite was
causing inflation and increasing the
flow of roman gold and silver coinage to
rival eastern nations when emperor
tiberius spoke of roman wealth
transported to hostile countries he
meant the parthian empire
they had inflicted humiliating military
defeats on rome
but now they were battling the empire
economically
ansi wishes to control the trade in
multicolored chinese silks and so blocks
the route to prevent them getting
through
bundles of thick chinese silk entering
the roman empire were carefully re-woven
and refashioned in syrian workshops some
of this coloured fabric was sold back to
the parthians for transfer further east
but most of the material was destined
for affluent to roman
consumers but in the surviving sources
it was the use of silk in female
fashions that drew the most comment
[Music]
these fabrics are imported at a vast
expense from nations that are unknown to
our merchants
now our matrons show as much of their
persons in public as they do to their
lovers in private
but men had also taken to the new
fashion conservative romans complained
that traditional togas made from coarse
linen or heavy wool were being replaced
with lighter and more comfortable part
silk costumes
now men wear silk clothing in the summer
because of its lightness but they do not
feel ashamed at one time we used to wear
leather military breastplates but
fashions have become so bizarre that now
even the toga is considered
unnecessarily heavy at least we have
left assyrian silk dresses to the women
for the time being
but there was an economic price to pay
for these purchases silks were imported
at great cost from distant nations and
every purchase strengthened foreign
rivals
silk spices pearls and incense were a
replenishable resource in the distant
east
but roman bullion used for imperial
coinage was a finite resource
and the mines that sustained the roman
economy were not limitless one day there
would be a reckoning
but in the meantime there were other
routes to the distant east that could be
exploited by ambitious roman merchants
for if parthia blocked the overland
roots
then the romans
would take to the seas
in 1847 an extraordinary find was made
near cananore in kerala coastal
southwest india
near the ocean shores within an eroding
sand dune local people discovered a
strange bronze container of ancient
origin and foreign design concealed
within this vessel were thousands of
pristine gold coins with sharp relief
images depicting roman emperors with
their imperial titles and classical gods
augustus nero metallic ancient faces
stirred up with the local indians close
to eight thousand gold roman aoray had
been buried at this site undisturbed for
almost two millennia
a clue can be found in the work of pliny
the elder
by the smallest computation india the
serez and the arabian peninsula take 100
million sisters from our empire every
year
that is the sum expended on our luxuries
and our women
strabo corroborates this reporting that
120 roman ships made trade voyages from
egypt to india every year in about ad50
a greek merchant guidebook called the
periplus of the erythraean sea describes
these roman voyages to india the
periplus confirmed that money was the
main roman export to southern india
where it was exchanged for silks ivory
spices and pearls
ships reaching these ports of trade take
on board full loads because of the
volume and quantity of pepper and
cinnamon
these ports offer a market mainly for a
great amount of money
vast quantities of bullion
lost from the empire
the seasonal monsoon meant that roman
ships rarely sailed further than the
southern tip of western india an area
known as limericke it was the merchants
who operated the further trade routes
who gave the romans some of their
earliest information on china the
periplus reports at the ganges you are
at the northernmost point of india
somewhere on the outer fringe where the
sea ends there is a very great inland
state called thaina
from this place silk floss yarn and
cloth are trafficked by land by way of
bactria to barry gaza silk is also taken
via the ganges river to limericke
roman merchants wondered if china could
be reached on land the periplus
speculated it is not easy to get to this
thiner only rarely do people come from
it and even then only a few
the area lies right under ursa minor it
is said thiner is connected to parts of
the pontus and the caspian sea
what lies beyond this region because of
extremes of storms the bitter cold and
the difficult terrain but also because
of some divine power of the gods
these places have not been explored
no roman traders dared to test these
theories and few tried to follow the
commercial traffic back to china
an ancient trade document known as the
museus papyrus confirms the importance
of this economic network to the roman
empire it refers to cargo removed from a
roman merchant ship which had just
returned from southern india the cargo
was valued at more than nine million
sisters and the roman state would have
collected quarter rate import taxes
worth more than two million sisters from
this single vessel this suggests that
eastern trade provided the roman empire
with perhaps a third of its essential
revenues more than 300 million sisters
in the private council of the emperor
vespasian pliny and his colleagues would
have debated the quandary of empire
the commerce that was diminishing roman
wealth was producing essential tax
revenues to finance the military regime
it was a double-edged sword
draining the empire whilst also
maintaining its armies
but what
could be done
[Music]
in the distant pharasan islands just off
the south coast of saudi arabia a worn
latin military inscription pokes out of
the white sands
for the emperor on behalf of the
vexilation of the second league triana
fortis and its auxiliary troops
castrichius aprenus
son of publius prefect of the port of
pharasan and the sea of hercules has
made and dedicated this monument
this port lays 600 miles or three weeks
sailing in fair weather from the
southern frontier of roman egypt
it was
the furthest roman outpost
the true edge of the empire
yet the port itself was a simple
functional site constructed from stone
cobbles stacked into ramparts
it included a castra containing a
headquarters barracks kitchens stables
storerooms and granaries
here near the entrance to the red sea
gulf a task force from the legio six
ferata the sixth ironclad legion had
guarded the main sailing routes to india
but it seems to have been more than that
the then emperor trajan looks to have
been planning a possible invasion route
for roman
conquest trajan fitted out a fleet for
the erythraean sea so that he might use
it to lay waste to the coasts of india
80 years after tiberius had issued his
warning the roman empire had begun to
act
north of the danube frontier the
mountainous kingdom of dakia had been
conquered by the emperor trajan in ad106
these renowned gold mining districts
were added to the roman economy
but this was not enough trajan also had
new plans for the distant east extending
roman interests into the indian ocean
and seizing the overland trade routes
leading through inner asia that same
year the roman legions in syria swept
through the neighbouring client kingdoms
of nabataea in southwest arabia the
caravan city of petra became a roman
possession and the empire gained control
over the main terminal nodes of the
inland incense trails
from here caravan trails led to the
yemen in southern arabia and crossed the
desert to connect with the
parthian-ruled persian gulf
perhaps trajan was already planning the
conquest of babylonia
expansion into arabia maximized
opportunities to acquire new routes for
intelligence gathering invasion or
resupply on his orders a canal was
re-cut to connect the nile near
alexandria with the head of the suez
gulf
and this water passage allowed roman war
galleys and supply ships to sail from
the mediterranean into the red sea
but how much did the romans know about
the distant east
and their ultimate goal
a greco-roman geographer named claudius
ptolemy produced a map of the known
world in the second century a.d for his
data and coordinates he referred to an
earlier work on world cartography
written by an authority called marinus
of tyre
marinus had received a merchant report
of a trade expedition to china from a
businessman of macedonian descent named
mayus titanius
it seems that in about 100 a.d
commercial agents managed by maius
joined caravans crossing iran and
bactria to reach the stone
tower from this site his agents should
attach themselves to further caravans
headed across the hand-controlled tarim
territories as far as inner china and
onwards to the reported capital of the
ceres
marianas says that a certain maius had
written down the measurements he himself
did not go but had sent others to the
ceres
when the group returned to roman syria
they offered a full account of their
exploits to maus describing all they had
witnessed in the distant land of the
ceres
from this marinus and other geographers
were able to create a basic outline of
the east including the location of some
major population centers
and so now the romans had their first
map of cerica
china
news spread through the empire and the
ceres became the subject of great
speculation the satirist juvenile
complained about domineering roman wives
interfering in the concerns of military
politics
this mattered to them because of
interruptions to their supplies of silk
they would interrogate their husbands to
ask
what are the intentions of the ceres
perhaps the emperor trajan also
considered the serras in his imperial
plans for the east
trajan began his conquest of the
parthian empire in 114 a.d
capturing armenia and seizing the minor
kingdoms of northern mesopotamia
triumphant legions marched into
babylonia and the kingdom of teresa
to the emperor
and in his moment of victory trajan
traveled down to the shore of the
persian gulf and inspected the ships
that were leaving for india
the emperor was already in his 60s and
perhaps beginning to feel the onset of
illness
he was shortly to suffer what may have
been a stroke and he died on the way
back to rome
then trajan came to the ocean when he
had observed its nature and had seen a
ship sailing to india he said
oh if only i was still young then i
would certainly have crossed over to
india
for he began to think about india and
was curious about their affairs
and he regarded alexander to have been
fortunate to have traveled there
and so for that brief moment trajan
dreamt of distant conquests and far-off
adventures
but little did he know he was standing
in the exact location where just two
decades earlier the chinese envoy gang
ying had paused on his journey west
and indeed ying had been sent to find
the ruler of dar chin
the emperor of rome
trajan
himself
in 1897 after crossing the blistering
deserts of southern iran
the han envoy gang ying
finally stood on the humid shores of the
persian gulf
ghan ying had already spent many arduous
weeks crossing inner asia on his secret
assignment
chinese intelligence suggested that a
new superpower had emerged in the far
west which matched the han empire in its
population size prosperity and military
capacity
informants claimed that the new empire
had been created from existing kingdoms
conquered by the authority of a great
autocratic ruler the situation resembled
how china had been unified by the qin
dynasty consequently this new empire of
the distant west received the name best
translated as
da chin
another
great china
gang ying had almost reached his
destination
he had almost found a route to rome
by following the euphrates north de
ziogma he would arrive at the heavily
militarized roman frontier
leggio
iv sithika the fourth scythian legion
was headquartered in zyugma and from
this frontier city the han ambassador
could be conveyed directly to rome
but as the civilizations converged
gang ying looked out across the waters
of the gulf
the seemingly endless expanse
sent a sickening fear through him
what if
there was nothing out
there protector general ban chao had won
back the taram territories the chinese
lost possession of the taran region in
189 when the usurper wang man briefly
seized power from the han dynasty the
oasis kingdoms refused to follow the new
acting emperor and broke their political
connection to china the thousand-mile
passage across the taram territories
became subject to numerous competing
powers and although large-scale silk
commerce continued
china had lost a direct route of
communication to bactria
the han reconquest and restoration of
the tarim kingdoms began in ad74 but it
required almost two decades to fully
accomplish
during these operations ban chao
re-established contact with uragi and
learned how the entire nation was now
under the command of a great king named
vaima kadvices
ruler of the newly formed khushan empire
a key middleman along the silk road
these new political connections were
crucial to maintaining chinese control
over the restored tarim territories the
kushans agreed favorable terms with the
chinese gaining an income of silk for
their compliance
but ban chao began to look
even further west
with power again cemented there was now
an opportunity to send han envoys to the
parthian empire
xiaoji and angxi and all the kingdoms as
far as the shores of the great sea more
than forty thousand lee away all offered
diplomatic gifts however they had to use
several successive interpreters to
communicate with us
parthia was now within the chinese
diplomatic system but what power might
challenge and check parthia in any
future struggle for international
dominance and more importantly what was
the ultimate destination for all the
chinese silk being trafficked west these
distant people obviously desired silk a
great deal
perhaps an agreement could be made
indian merchants provided the answer
when they revealed their commercial
contacts with rome objects from the
roman empire were being trafficked
through bactria and these provided
unique glimpses into the world beyond
the great southern ocean
eastern peoples could make glass items
but they were generally small and
clouded with impurities in contrast the
romans manufactured beautiful
translucent glass-blown vessels that
were tinted vibrant colours by using
unique mineral extracts
and indeed perhaps ban chao gazed upon
such items while he carefully questioned
indian traders about the power and
wealth of distant
dar chin
he decided to select an envoy named gang
ying to make the journey and establish
contact with the unknown emperor of the
far west
han envoys adopted the guise of
prosperous merchants as they trekked
west from the taram territories to arya
in eastern iran they avoided the route
through northern iran which passed
through the main political centers of
the parthian empire this was a secret
mission
gang ying selected a southern route and
led his small party west through
mountains and deserts towards the
ancient district of susa this led to the
persian gulf the who hanshu describes
the perilous journey into the unknown
from unsee if you travel 3400 the li
west you reach the kingdom of amman
leaving amman and travelling 3600 li you
reach the kingdom of sibin leaving sibin
and travelling south you cross a river
then going southwest you reach the
kingdom of yulio after 960 li this is
the extreme western frontier of ansi
leaving there and heading south you
embark on the sea
and then reach
dar chin
but when gan ying arrived there were no
roman ships in sight
the chinese had no knowledge of the
arabian peninsula or the extent of the
african continent to his horror gang
ying learned that the southern ocean
extended west for a further thousand
miles
baffled by the geography of babylonia he
couldn't seek assistance from local
authorities due to the clandestine
nature of his mission
he reasoned that darchin had to be
situated at this western edge of the
great ocean because they sent trade
vessels to india
but this western empire was also
surrounded by a great sea the
mediterranean
so what now
when gang ying asked if he could sail to
darjin he received confusing responses
from the many foreign merchants and
sailors present at charism
some merchants thought that the chinese
travelers wanted to reach roman egypt by
sailing 3000 miles around the entire
coast of arabia others may have assumed
that these foreigners plan to reach the
italian capital by circumnavigating
africa
but there could also have been an
element of exploitation and the mariners
may have exaggerated the risks and
duration of their voyage to guarantee
they were paid higher sums for
undertaking the hazards of the journey
in the ninth year
during the reign of emperor her the
protector general ban chao sent gan ying
to dar chin
he reached ciao xi next to a large sea
he wanted to cross it but the sailors on
the western frontier of sea said to him
the ocean is huge
those making the round trip can do it in
three months if the winds are favorable
however if you encounter winds that
delay you it can take two years
gang ying did not have the temperament
determination and inner resolve of jung
chen
at the edge of the known world where
jung-chen had pushed on
he turned back
ban chao concluded that it was not
possible to reach roman territory by any
acceptable means
the expedition report suggested that
rome was too distant to have any
influence in central asia and ban chao
did not realize how close gang ying had
come to establishing contact with the
roman empire
had gan ying been successful in his
mission to rome he would have been
brought before the military emperor
trajan in the first year of his reign if
gang ying had overcome his trepidations
correctly apprised the situation and
then pushed onwards chinese ambassadors
would have sat amongst roman senators
during the dacian victory games in rome
that same year the vast ocean urges men
to think of their country
get home sick
and some of them even die
in ad 107 the leading tarim kingdoms
revolted from chinese rule and han
authorities withdrew back to the hershey
frontier
trajan's attempted conquest of the
parthian empire began in ad-114
the romans captured babylonia but
uprisings across the middle east and
parthian counter-attacks forced the
legions to withdraw from the region
hadrian who succeeded trajan as emperor
abandoned the parthian conflict
[Music]
the dream
was dead
roman china would not meet on the
battlefields
of central asia
strangers had arrived on the southern
frontiers of the han empire
exhausted and confused they had tried to
communicate with port officials using an
unknown language and been immediately
escorted to the chinese capital lua yang
for investigation
china was managed by a vast civil
service and the han palace complex
resembled a self-contained city filled
with scholars archivists ministers and
bureaucrats as part of official protocol
han officials had subjected the
strangers to a list of stock questions
designed to ascertain the scale and
character of the regime they claimed to
represent
and according to the book of later han
these men with their strange garments
and close cropped hair
were roman
representatives of anton
marcus aurelius antoninus
and after careful questioning the
foreign delegates were granted an
audience with the han emperor
and summoned to the ornate
inner court
in 161 a.d parthia declared war on the
roman empire by annihilating a legion in
armenia and leaving the governor of
cappadocia slain on the battlefield
after half a century of peace and
stability the legions had had enough and
prepared to finally obliterate the
parthian menace
rome
was going to war
and required eastern allies
envoys and commercial agents were sent
with dispatches to summon assistance
would the kushan empire join the romans
in this war against their mutual enemy
and what of the ceres could the steel
equipped superpower in the far east
offer further assistance
but the question remained
how to contact
this distant empire
for those courageous enough to undertake
a voyage into the hazardous unknown the
ocean might provide a direct route to
the distant east
but there had been major developments
since the time of the periplus roman
ships were now sailing around sri lanka
to visit eastern india and traverse the
bay of bengal ptolemy had used new
information from these merchants to
construct a map of southeast asia
including the shape and location of the
thousand-mile long malay peninsula known
as the golden cherceries and merchants
had discovered a shortcut across this
barrier by landing at the narrow craw
isthmus they made an overland journey to
the far coast
on the eastern shore other trade vessels
awaited to take merchants across the
gulf of thailand to reach vietnam and
southern china a land the traders called
sinai
we have also learnt about the interior
of asia as far as the golden cherceries
and the route to katagara
the land and capital of the serez is
situated above the sinai the region east
is unknown because of marshland giant
reeds and the impediment of river
crossings
perhaps this is a reference to flooded
paddy fields and bamboo forests but the
details are vague
but it was enough for ptolemy to produce
a basic outline map of southeast asia
and the likely site of a great inland
capital known as sinai or
thinai metropolis
a trade sailing from roman egypt to the
mysterious land of the ceres was
therefore entirely feasible
but the sea voyage from egypt to china
would span a quarter of the globe and
cross 8 000 miles of ocean
the men that marcus aurelius selected
for this task must have accepted this
mission to voyage into the distant
unknown and established direct relations
with the mysterious steel-equipped
empire with trepidation
and so in ad 166 a roman ship
circumnavigated the malay peninsula and
crossed the gulf of thailand to enter
the south china sea the roman crew had
probably spent over 14 months at sea or
in various foreign ports
sailing north along the coast of vietnam
their ship docked at a military outpost
called rinan
the southernmost periphery of han china
the two greatest empires of the ancient
world
were about to make first contact
[Music]
the exhausted romans who arrived at the
port would have seen numerous military
personnel dressed in strange uniforms
and carrying unfamiliar weaponry
these wide-eyed travelers realized that
this wasn't a mere trading partner
another peoples to be subdued
they were dealing with a vast
militarized empire
like rome
it was a thousand-mile journey from
renan to lua yang along multi-laned
chinese highways which were twice the
width of the largest roman roads at 10
mile intervals postal stations provided
couriers and state officials with fresh
horses and offered facilities for
overnight accommodation the awestruck
romans would have seen tall watchtowers
in the chinese countryside and observed
formidable defensive walls surrounding
han cities
they marveled at the thick beige
coloured silk fabrics worn even by poor
people of low status and high quality
steel was used for ordinary battle gear
and common work tools chinese coins did
not widely display images of the emperor
nor did army emblems and public statues
so the roman envoys must have wondered
who this emperor was
a general like trajan or perhaps a
philosopher statesman like marcus
aurelius
there was soon to find out
during the reign of emperor juan
the king of dar chin
anton sent envoys from beyond the
frontiers through renan
he offered elephant tusks rhino horn and
turtle shell this was the very first
time that there was direct communication
but the tribute brought was neither
precious nor rare raising suspicion that
earlier accounts of dar chin
might be exaggerated
it seems the hardships and stresses of
the extended voyage and travel through
china had taken a heavy toll on the crew
the chinese had expected the romans to
present diplomatic gifts including
western gemstones precious red coral
brilliantly dyed fabrics and marvelous
coloured glassware
but the envoys had been forced to trade
sell or surrender their diplomatic gifts
to secure safe passage in eastern ports
or maybe they were just roman merchants
who had been issued with statements of
introduction and commissioned to see if
it was possible to contact the ceres
some members of the han court may have
observed the gifts and questioned
earlier accounts of dar chin was it
really a wealthy superpower
the meeting was concluded and the
antonine envoys were escorted back to
rinan and their waiting ship
although the chinese prepared for
further contact no fleet of roman ship
ever came
no one arrived not even opportunistic
merchants searching for lucrative new
trade opportunities
chinese officials sought explanation for
the lack of contact and finally
concluded that rome was not as wealthy
or as politically ambitious
as their previous records had stated
but that
was not the reason
no one returned
for if these envoys had returned safely
to egypt
they would have found the roman empire
in an unprecedented
mortal crisis
in a.d 165 after the legions had
successfully invaded the parthian empire
they captured the capital city of
seleucia and occupied babylonia
but during the winter months an unknown
disease had broken out amongst the
troops
this had forced the roman army to
abandon the war and retreat to syria
but in doing so
they brought the pandemic
home with them
an ancestral form of smallpox the
disease killed or disabled up to a third
of people in affected areas these
figures are confirmed by papyri tax
records detailing the manpower available
in certain agricultural villages
some rural centres lost over 70 percent
of their adult male population as people
fled agricultural estates threatened by
the infection
the result was failed harvests and food
shortages
those who did not die were often left
maimed or seriously incapacitated
casualty rates were highest in
overcrowded cities including alexandria
and rome which had prolonged warm
temperatures during the summer one of
the main factors that increased
infection rates was that roman society
encouraged public bathing as a mass
recreational activity
the pandemic devastated the roman army
and reduced its ability to control the
northern frontiers the mounted warrior
peoples of the eurasian steppe having a
lucky advantage a greater resistance to
the disease due to their cattle droving
cultures and immunity acquired by their
frequent exposure to cow and horse boxes
but in the empire the antonine disease
remained at epidemic levels for over a
decade the movement of army personnel
was a key vector in the early spread of
the disease but maritime commerce also
propagated and intensified the epidemic
people seemingly in good health at the
beginning of their voyage could develop
full symptoms in the trip and infect
other crew and passengers in the close
confines of the ship
crowded markets filled with people from
distant regions also offered a chain of
infection for renewed outbreaks
whole armies were lost after the
parthian victory because a devastating
disease affected the greater part of the
roman population and all the troops in
rome italy and the provinces succumbed
to the sickness
this microscopic viral enemy was an
unrelenting force of nature that rome
could not overcome with military might
and discipline as the empire faltered
hordes of germanic invaders threatened
to overrun the exposed northern
frontiers after decades of conflict even
the emperor could not avoid his fate and
he too succumbed to the invisible enemy
and unknown to the romans
on the other side of the world
the same disease had struck the han
empire before it could even reach the
roman frontier
the chinese had named it the barbarian
boils because the infection spread
initially by step peoples caused
numerous painful blisters to erupt on
the skin of the sufferer
chinese records confirmed that an ad
ad-162
this pandemic killed or debilitated
one-third of hand troops on the northern
frontiers
mounted step nomads immediately took
advantage of the situation and overran
the unprotected borders
the roads came under attack and
communications were broken there was
widespread sickness in the army and
three or four out of every 10 men
died
in the han empire the effects of the
disease were worsened by severe drought
and famine that caused unrest among the
large rural population
from 170 a.d onwards a revolutionary
taoist sect began to gain influence in
chinese society
this mass movement was led by a cult of
charismatic faith healers who planned to
seize governmental power from the han
they declared that the han regime had
lost the mandate of heaven and their
uprising would restore health vitality
and prosperity to a decaying world
the militia-based supporters and
devotees of this movement wore
distinctive golden yellow strips of
fabric around their heads this led to
the organization becoming known as the
yellow scarves
the blue sky
has died
the yellow sky
is coming
and in ad 184 the yellow scarves led a
violent popular uprising against the han
government involving millions of
peasants and thousands of rebellious
troops
to restore order the han regime gave
greater political military and tax
collecting powers to provincial
governments local rulers and prominent
chinese generals these new warlords
suppressed the yellow scarves rebellion
but then fought to claim power for
themselves
thus splitting the chinese empire into
competing factions that commanded large
districts as self-governing realms and
began levying armies from their peasant
populations
the empire
fragmented and china no longer looked to
the distant west
the mysterious land of darchin
became a legend
during this tumultuous era the han
dynasty collapsed
the parthians were overthrown
and the kushan empire
disintegrated rome persevered
but the plague marked the beginning of
the end
at least
in the western empire
the land of silk is in the most remote
part of asia and those crossing the
indian ocean can locate it at the
furthest place north it is a great
distance from the persian gulf and from
the island the indians called celadepa
and the greeks taprebane
by the 6th century the eastern roman
empire was recovering from the shock
waves caused by the fall of rome and the
barbarian capture of italy
the romans had managed to revive their
commerce in the red sea but their
vessels rarely crossed the indian ocean
nonetheless the romans who sailed these
truncated routes had heard old stories
of tsinitza the distant land of silk
china
in this new era the roman emperors of
constantinople faced a dangerous
opponent in the form of the rival
sassanian empire in persia like their
the
parthian
empire blocked roman access to the
so-called silk routes through iran
the indian philosophers called brahmans
assert that if someone were to stretch a
cord from tsinitsa it has to pass
through persia until it reaches roman
territory persia is therefore the
midpoint of the world according to this
measurement perhaps they speak the truth
sinitza is extremely far to the east but
its silk reaches persia in only a short
time beyond sinitsa there is no
navigation and no inhabitants
then emperor justinian dreamed of
breaking this persian monopoly and
ending the flow of roman wealth into a
hostile empire but before he could act
on his wishes
fate intervened
it began in 535 a.d
the skies began
to darken
the sun had been dimmed by a screen of
dust and volcanic debris in the high
atmosphere that blocked essential solar
light and warmth crops failed and famine
followed this was followed in 541 a.d by
the first outbreak of a major new
pandemic emerging in egypt and sweeping
across the entire roman empire it was a
lethal bubonic infection the empire was
once again struck to its knees
by plague
all this put great stress on the roman
economy as the price of eastern imports
skyrocketed a solution to the silk
routes supply dilemma was urgently
needed
and so in 550 a.d an unexpected response
came from a group of distant travelers
nestorian monks who had ventured inland
beyond persia
about this time some of the monks
arrived from india they knew that it was
a matter of importance to the emperor
justinian that the romans should no
longer purchase silk from the persians
they said that they had spent a long
time in a country which was beyond the
many nations of india a place called
surrender and in surrender they had
accurately learned how it would be
possible for silk to be produced in the
land of the romans
the emperor scrutinized the matter most
carefully and asked
if the story
were true
the only way to find out the truth was
to have the monks demonstrate their
knowledge in front of the emperor
himself
but that would be a risky business
the monks affirmed that certain worms
were the producers of silk these insects
acted on instinct to perform this task
of silk production there was no
practical way to transport the living
worms but they could be easily generated
and bred each insect produces countless
numbers of eggs from which the worms
emerge
when they had spoken the emperor gave
them great encouragement and promised
many rewards if they could demonstrate
these facts with a practical test
[Music]
the grey eggs of the silkworm were no
larger than a pinhead and the minuscule
hatchlings weighed barely half a
milligram but they would eventually grow
into large grubs before spinning cocoons
in these silk chrysolids they pupate
into moths and their cocoons provide the
filament for silk thread
but how could delicate insect x be
transported back to constantinople
safely and secretly
it was a persian man who demonstrated in
byzantium the origin of silkworms
previously unknown to the romans he set
out from the land of the ceres with the
eggs of the worms contained in a wooden
cylinder and delivered them safely to
byzantium the monks returned to
surrender and brought eggs back to
byzantium they succeeded in turning them
into worms in the manner described and
from that they established silk
production in the land of the romans for
the rest of time
and indeed from these small beginnings
constantinople would develop its own
vibrant silk industry enriching the
eastern roman empire and shifting the
balance of economic power away from
persia the greatest secret of the ceres
was no longer exclusive the fabric
weaves now belong to constantinople and
a legacy of silk would guarantee its
prosperity
for many years to come
the silk roots had bound together the
ancient world connecting greek legacy in
central asia with the distant ambitions
of han china for almost a thousand years
steel from the distant east in the
possession of parthian warlords had
thwarted roman expansion
and ensured their legions never reached
the distant battlefields of bactria and
rome had therefore never managed to
equal the eastern conquests of alexander
the great and roman cities and garrison
outposts never emerged on the frontiers
of fergana to challenge chinese
supremacy
nevertheless the commercial networks
established through silk routes
delivered resources generated profits
and created a vast interconnected world
economy leading the vast empires of rome
and china to inevitable contact through
peaceful commerce
rather than direct warfare
but of course an interconnected world
brings its own challenges
and those very roots that brought
wonders from east to west and west to
east also carried devastating plague and
waves of chaos
and perhaps ultimately this was the true
significance of the ancient silk routes
that connected the civilizations of han
china and imperial rome the ancestral
foundations
of the interconnectedness
of our world
[Music]
you